estamos ante la reedición de la guerra
fría
el conflicto de ucrania o las primaveras
árabes han puesto de manifiesto que el
gobierno de vladímir putin tiene
intereses muy distintos a los de eeuu y
la unión europea estas diferencias se
están materializando en enfrentamientos
violentos con muertos y heridos hasta
qué punto está europa las puertas de una
gran guerra hoy vamos a responder a esta
pregunta y lo vamos a hacer de la mano
de gema en nuestra nueva colaboradora
que ha estado viviendo en lituania
durante el último año y colaborando ni
más ni menos que con la otan
hasta 2013 ucrania era un país que no
daba mucho de que hablar era una más de
las antiguas repúblicas soviéticas que
no pertenecían ni a la unión europea ni
a la otan y poca cosa más
nadie predijo que un país aparentemente
tan tranquilo pueda desencadenar todos
los quebraderos de cabeza que ha traído
ni que fuera a ser uno de los países que
más han influido en la política global
en los últimos años desde el estallido
del euro maidán y su consecuente guerra
por los territorios del este y la
anexión ilegal de rusia de crimea
ucrania ha sido el punto de inflexión de
un orden mundial aparentemente tranquilo
y de un bonito periodo de paz para los
eeuu y rusia aunque ojo las tensiones
venían de antes los guerras suelen
empezar por un pequeño incidente señor
embajador ya desde la guerra de georgia
en 2008 la primavera árabe y el contexto
actual de guerra en siria ambas
superpotencias han estado apoyando a los
grupos opuestos
ahora bien y dejando atrás el contexto
histórico si ya han habido problemas
antes entre la otan y rusia por
conflictos en otros países porque el de
ucrania es tan importante bien la
respuesta es en realidad bastante
sencilla en el conflicto de ucrania es
la primera vez que rusia se ha
anexionado el territorio de un país
soberano basándose en la existencia de
minorías rusas oprimidas lo que hizo
saltar las alarmas en las repúblicas
bálticas de estonia letonia y lituania
estas antiguas repúblicas soviéticas
ahora parte de la otan y de la unión
europea en cuenta con un porcentaje de
población étnicamente ruso muy elevado
especialmente los casos de estonia y
letonia en los que la población rusa
alcanza el 25 por ciento que haya tanta
gente de origen ruso en el báltico no es
casualidad ni porque los rusos tengan
ahí sus casas de vacaciones aunque
también sino que nos remontamos a la
época de stalin que no era muy amigo de
todo aquello que no fuera ruso es decir
todas las minorías que vivían en las
repúblicas soviéticas que hizo esta ley
básicamente las deportaciones a siberia
que todos conocemos cogió lituanos
estonios letones y ojo gente de los
otros países también y los mandó a
siberia mientras mandaba ciudadanos
rusos a habitar en estas zonas esto
unido a la imposición del ruso como
lengua obligatoria y de la cultura rusa
sobre estos países debería haber
homogeneizado a todas
repúblicas soviéticas pero como la
historia nos demuestra al final los
nacionalismos acabado empresarios
y repito que esto no pasa únicamente los
bálticos sino que también se encuentran
con este problema otros países como
georgia bielorrusia o la misma ucrania
la diferencia con los bálticos es que al
ser miembros de la unión europea y la
otan podría esperarse de ellos una
cierta estabilidad y es cierto así a
priori las minorías rusas no son ningún
motivo de inestabilidad para ellos en el
corto plazo pero están ahí en unos
territorios que antaño fueron invadidos
por rusia y a sabiendas de que a la
mínima de cambio útil podría utilizar a
estos ciudadanos rusos como excusa para
básicamente cualquier cosa así a primera
vista cualquier intervención rusa en
países soberanos y pertenecientes a la
otan parecería una locura ya que en tal
caso los países afectados tendrían
derecho a invocar el artículo 5 de la
otan que básicamente implicaría una
tercera guerra mundial las partes
convienen en que un ataque armado contra
una o varias de ellas ocurrió en europa
o en américa del norte será considerado
como un ataque dirigido contra todos y
en consecuencia convienen en que sitel
ataque se produce cada una de ellas
asistirá a la parte o partes atacadas
tomando individualmente y de acuerdo con
las otras las medidas que juzgue
necesario pero si nos fijamos en cómo
está actuando la otan y rusia en torno a
esta zona
la idea no parece tan descabellada
empezando por la otan y su cumbre el
pasado mes de julio en varsovia donde
los líderes de los 28 miembros entre
otras cosas se comprometieron a reforzar
la presencia militar en los bálticos y
en polonia al considerar
rusia una amenaza real en este contexto
cabe decir que el despliegue ya había
empezado antes de la cumbre el pasado
mes de junio con la misión anaconda la
misión a la conda fue la mayor maniobra
militar desde la guerra fría del siglo
pasado un movimiento en mi opinión
innecesario en un contexto de escalada
de tensión como es en el que nos
encontramos y en el que además aunque ya
se sabía se llegó a la conclusión de que
la otan no podía defender a los bálticos
en caso de que rusia decidiera invadir
les mientras tanto rusia que también
está molesta por las relaciones entre la
otan y ucrania y por cómo se le ha
demonizado según ellos dicen en la
cumbre de varsovia tampoco se queda
quieta
aviones molestando a barcos de la otan
en el báltico movimientos militares en
su lado de la frontera y la hiper
militarización de kaliningrado un tema
que da para vídeo propio los misiles
desplazados por rusia a la región de
kaliningrado inquietan a lituania y
polonia son solo algunos de los
movimientos que están haciendo que en
bruselas se muerdan las uñas y soviética
está dispuesta a administrar a un
submarino desobediente la unión
soviética no se habían separado eso es
lo que queríamos que ustedes pensarán
tan nervioso se están poniendo en
bruselas ya principios de este año un
general británico ligado a la otan
publicó un libro con un título tan
devastador como 2007 la guerra con rusia
en el que incluso da una fecha exacta de
una invasión rusa sobre los bálticos
para ello ha imaginado un escenario
plausible para el próximo año en el que
la organización se encuentra con
problemas de financiación lo difícil de
echarse un farol y sobre cuánto hay que
datos y de capacidades para ayudar a los
bálticos en esa invasión ya no tan
sorpresa y este escenario en concreto se
vuelve cada vez más real cada vez que un
candidato a la presidencia de los eeuu
menciona a rusia
en efecto trump también tiene su parte
del pastel en todo esto el candidato
republicano últimamente ha soltado
perlas tan brillantes como que
abandonaría la otan si los demás países
no incrementan sus presupuestos
militares que no ayudaría a los bálticos
en caso de invasión rusa y que crimea
está mucho mejor bajo el control de
putin con invasiones y conflictos
armados a la vista por ambas partes como
veis las diferencias existentes entre la
guerra fría del siglo pasado y la
situación actual no son demasiadas me
gustaría decir que no hay nada escrito
sobre a dónde va a llevar todo esto en
royal bites y a vosotros qué os parece
creéis que estamos ante una nueva guerra
fría o en una nueva guerra fría y a
dónde nos va a llevar esta escalada de
tensión tan innecesaria en la que nos
estamos metiendo espero vuestros
comentarios y si os ha gustado el vídeo
darle al like
y suscribiros al canal que es gratis